so our keynotes before lunch today
is Dave Danielson he is here from
breakthrough energy ventures and the
director for the Scott Institute for
energy innovation dr. J Whittaker is
going to provide us with an introduction
hello welcome back to second day of
energy week I was out this morning
teaching class so I missed up until now
so I hope all it's been going well I'm
here to introduce actually a friend of
mine who I have known for some time when
he first took over as a program manager
in the early days the founding days in
fact of arpa-e I emailed him to ask him
a random question thinking there's no
way I was gonna get a response this was
2009 they had thousands and thousands of
applications to to get started with
arpa-e and email me back within minutes
asking me questions and as such that
started a long term communication loop
that we've had for over a decade now
it's been lovely
he currently now is a managing director
for science and breakthrough energy
ventures he also serves as a Precourt
energy scholar at Stanford he's
considered a global expert in the
development of next-generation clean
technologies and the creation of new R&D
organization models for high-impact
clean innovation so he also works at a
beyond arpa-e he also is assistant
secretary of energy efficiency and
renewable energy EERE where he led the
world's largest government clean energy
innovation funding organization before
joining ye re and arpa-e Danielson was
sorry before joining URI
he was also employee number one as I
mentioned in arpa-e and has been you
know impactful in this field in main
different ways so without further ado
dating
okay well good afternoon how's everybody
doing
yeah all right I'm really excited to be
here today Jay thanks so much for that
kind introduction you know this is the
second time I've been out here in just
two or three months you know and one
thing I wanted to compliment Jay you and
and I you know see you at Carnegie
Mellon and the whole ecosystem out here
is but I'd say you know ten years ago
when I was working in this space of kind
of energy clean tech climate tech you
know it might not have been really
obvious to me to come up to Carnegie
Mellon and spend a lot of time but I can
say you know with all the great work
that this community is done to really
build the ecosystem out here now for me
you know Carnegie Mellon is like a key
destination you know I'd say there are
four or five places that I want to hit
every two or three months and this is
one of them and so I really want to
compliment you for what you've achieved
and so I'm here today really to tell you
about about something new that I'm a
part of it's called breakthrough energy
ventures it's a new fund that's
investing in transformative energy
climate tech startups with a really kind
of a big impact longview and you know
I'd say most importantly what I want to
do is kind of introduce you to break
their energy ventures who we are where
we are what we're all about but probably
equally importantly I want to tell you
about some of the areas that that early
on in our getting up and running we've
been up and running for a little about a
year are some areas investment thesis
areas some areas where we want to really
back great entrepreneurs and innovators
to get after some of these big big
problems in energy and and in greenhouse
gas emissions reduction and I think the
one thing you know I got a chance to
come here three or four months ago as
part of a tour that myself and a number
of my colleagues did around the country
where we we engaged with with more than
130 top innovation organizations all
around the world and one thing I really
want to kind of emphasize in terms of
what breakthrough is all about and in
terms of the partnerships that we can
form is when you know we had that you
know big clean tech investment boom many
of you will remember
about a decade ago they kind of had a
bit of a crash and you know we're coming
back out of that right now in a pretty
exciting way but one thing I've noticed
is I think that people were encouraged
during those leaner years you know a
couple three a few leaner years in there
where there wasn't a lot of venture
investment in the space to think a
little smaller and so if there's one
thing I want you to take away from my
talk today is that in my mind it turns
over kicking with us it's time to think
big again and so I want to tell you
about some of the problems that we're
really interested in but most
importantly we want you know I know many
of you have really big ideas and often
you can't get support for those ideas
those are the ideas that that we want to
talk to you about a breakthrough
so to tee this up you know the way we
view this is that energy and climate are
the defining challenge of our time you
know they're about on the order of seven
billion people on earth today and
interestingly almost six billion of
those people are in less developed
countries countries that aren't they
don't have very high GDP that aren't
using a lot of energy by 2050 the UN
projects that will have closer to ten
million people on this planet and all of
those two billion people we're going to
add are going to be people in those less
developed countries and so we've got
about 33% more people coming on board
between now and 2050 and if you look at
the aspirations of those people to get
to kind of Human Development Index that
that's that's up around what we see in
more developed countries they're gonna
have to increase their their energy
services that they're consuming on a per
capita basis by at least five times so
we have 33% more people all of those in
these less developed countries all those
people are looking for a 5x increase in
the amount of energy services and and
other resource services that they are
that they want to consume to live a life
that's I think that's at a par in terms
of quality of life with what many folks
in more developed countries have at the
same time our greatest scientists are
telling us well we need to be providing
so many more resources over the next 30
years the best scientists in the world
have made it clear to us now that we
need to reduce our greenhouse gas
emissions by at least 80 percent or 5x
over the next just over the next 30
years going to 2050 so to me this is our
finding challenge right we've got to
provide a lot more resources and
services to people so we can get the
global middle class growing and create
human wellbeing at the same time we've
got a 5x challenge in terms of reducing
our emissions so this is a huge
challenge a huge opportunity and the way
I like to frame this up is in the
context of a 70 Gigaton per year
greenhouse gas emissions gap and so if
you look at just about where we are
today we're at about 50 Giga tons per
year of emissions and if you look at all
of the projections for where we might go
the middle case projection which i think
is a little bit unoptimized ik is at
about 80 and so if you look at that
future where we may be headed versus
where we need to go to there's a 70 Giga
ton gap which is pretty significant and
the way that we view this is that we're
quite optimistic there are a lot of
great technologies that are now in the
market are coming down in costs we have
solar wind that electric vehicles LEDs
we've got a lot of solutions that are
getting into the market and rapidly
penetrating it so there's a lot of great
work that needs to be done in
accelerating that the deployment of
technologies that we already have today
but we also see it I say especially Bill
Gates who is really behind breakthrough
energy ventures there's a breakthrough
energy technology gap where there are a
number of sectors and areas where we
don't have good technologies yet in the
market or yet developed and that there's
a huge need and opportunity for us to
both scale up what we have today but
we've also got to invest in the R&D and
building the disruptive startups that
are going to deliver solutions in the
next 10 15 20 years in areas where we
don't have solutions today and that's
really what motivated Bill Gates to in
2015 going into the cop21 Paris
agreement in the months ahead of that he
reached out and engaged with the leaders
of all the major economies and he said
you know what we need to solve this
breakthrough energy technology gap and
he challenged them to double their
energy R&D over the next five years
across all the major economies and on
his side of the table he said if you're
willing to double your investments I'm
willing to double down on mine and I'm
going to
recruit some of the most influential
entrepreneurs and investors who are
representing the most high net worth
individuals on the planet to do it with
me and that resulted in what actually
going back the there was an announcement
a big announcement of a new initiative
that came out of that conversation on
the government side is called mission
innovation which was a commitment by all
the major economies to double their
energy R&D over five years where I'd say
the gross majority of all those
companies by all those countries by the
way are on a path to doubling and on the
private side Bill Gates recruited a
couple dozen key individuals to join him
in what was called a breakthrough Energy
Coalition who are committing to double
down in quotes double down on their
investments on the private side to help
support the creation of new startups in
the area and then over the course that
was in 2015 the end of 2015 was was cop
and mission innovation breakthrough
Energy Coalition the course of 2016
bill reached out to the key people in
his network who he knew really cared
about this problem and over the course
of that year recruited 20 of these
visionary leaders from all around the
world to join him in creating a billion
dollar fund that would invest in these
startups in these transformative
greenhouse gas emissions reducing
financially viable new startups and so
what's exciting to me is that you not
only have people like Jeff Bezos Vinodh
Khosla Michael Bloomberg John doar but
you also have people from all over the
world you got hostile partner from
Germany the founder of SA P you've got
Mukesh Ambani the wealthiest man in
India you've got Jack Ma from China and
a number of others so this is truly a
global group and I actually did the
rough calculation yesterday this group
represents on the order of 500 billion
dollars of net worth and so these kind
of people taking this problem seriously
and putting real money into it is a big
deal and and so breakthrough energy
ventures was launched at the beginning
of 2017 with a led by these investors
and there are a few things are a little
different
what we're doing compared to what's been
done in the past the the first I'd say
is this group the this group of very
influential folks who can get things
done that need to get done and who have
the capital to to push successful
companies forward but but separate from
that we've done a few other things
differently with this fund it's a as
many of you know energy resource
innovation climate innovation takes time
so this isn't a ten-year fund like we're
used to in venture capital this is a
20-year fund so we have the ability to
build companies over the long haul to
build incredibly valuable companies
we're not constrained by that that kind
of short window that I think is hurt
hurt the venture industry as it relates
to clean tech in the in the 1.0 boom
we're also taking a different approach
in terms of team building we have about
20 people on board now who have a very
broad spectrum of expertise all the way
from investors and entrepreneurs and
company builders to people who have
government experience policy experience
people who are scientists and
technologists and engineers and folks
from industry and so we have a very
different view in terms of assessing
companies and in terms of helping those
companies succeed when they go forward
I'd say the most significant element of
this fund is that it is exclusively
focused on backing companies that are
working on solutions that have
entitlement who have that have
possibility to have a huge impact on
greenhouse gas emissions and the the
filter or the the bogey that we're
putting out there is that we're
interested in companies that are
developing solutions or sets of
solutions that if fully deployed in 2050
could have at least half a Giga ton of
impact on reducing greenhouse gas
emissions and that's about 1% of today's
of today's emissions and so from our
perspective that's the the opportunity
to challenge the partnership that we
want to put forward to you and other
innovators all around the world is one
of those half Giga ton impact problems
and what are your ideas to build great
companies around those and we call this
the half Giga ton year challenge and so
what you just kind of abstract what's
half a Giga ton right and so I wanted to
kind of frame it up for you
half a Giga ton is about 250 gigawatts
of wind or solar replacing call or about
50 billion gallons per year of zero
carbon transport fuels like like second
generation biofuels so this kind of
frames up how big we're talking here and
to put that in comparison 2016 over the
history of mankind we deployed about 500
gigawatts of wind power about twice that
half gig at time and then if you look at
how you know the 50 billion gallons is
about a third of all of us gasoline
demand today so you know a half a Giga
ton win is is a really just put it in
perspective is it really it's a high bar
there aren't a huge number of problems
that if you solve them our half Giga ton
kind of problems but those are the
problems we're interested in and in
terms of this 70 Giga ton per year gap I
wanted to also frame up the economic
opportunity and I was trying to think of
a good comparison about you know how
many large companies are likely to be
formed if we succeed in this 70 Giga ton
gap closing and so I looked at Exxon
Mobil if you look at their amount of
production of fossil fuels it was about
0.6 around a half a Giga ton per year
last year and that company's worth about
80 billion dollars and so if you take
about just say 70 Giga tons so there's
140 your seventy divided by 0.5 half
Aggie ton more than a hundred Exxon
Mobil kind of economic opportunities are
on the table out to 2050 so this is a
big huge opportunity so that's why we
think we can create a huge impact but
also create huge companies by doing what
we're looking to do at breakthrough
energy ventures so I wanted to frame it
up you know that we were trying to think
a little bit differently you know there
there were some successes but a lot of
failures in clean tech 11.0 so we've
been trying to think hard about how are
we going to do things differently you
know other than a multidisciplinary team
amazing set of backers and a 20-year
window those are all good start but we
also wanted to think a little bit
differently and really get deep into
what we see is the mega trends that are
going to be really driving the next kind
of 10 20 30 years as it relates to
energy and climate so the first is that
we are encouraged and we're seeing
motion action progress on the on the
part of global
government's taking action on climate
things are moving in the right direction
I said they're moving slowly but they're
moving in the right direction but I'd
say more importantly there are what we
see is more inevitable mega trends that
we want to be aware of and we want to be
investing around the first is what I
would say is very low cost
you know ultra low-cost intermittent of
wind and solar so when I was a when I
was at the Department of Energy we were
you know paying the SunShot grand
challenge to try to get solar to a buck
a watt which is on the order of five or
six cents per kilowatt hour everyone
thought was crazy now we're seeing in
the market we're seeing three four cents
per kilowatt hour solar projects we're
seeing you know two cents and below
projects being done for wind and so you
you can't get those kind of electricity
prices at scale in many places so this
is disruptive this is a transformation
and our analysis says it's going to
continue to come down the other one is
lithium-ion battery cost reductions and
vehicle electrification it's been
shocking how quickly we've seen that
lithium-ion battery pack cost go from
more than $1,000 per kilowatt hour when
I started the Department of Energy to
now were you know approaching a hundred
right and so it's phenomenal progress
and when we do our analysis and we look
at where it can go we think can go a lot
lower so we're very bullish about where
lithium-ion batteries and where electric
vehicle deployment is going the shale
boom and cheap gas so this has been a
revolution just in the last few years
here in North America where we've got $3
per mm BTU gas we've got a lot of it
available so you know that's a mega
trend that we need to be aware of
investing around looking for
opportunities at the same time the
horizontal drilling and multi zonal
stimulation technology that's been
developed there is been on its own kind
of exponential learning curve and that's
something that we're paying a lot of
attention to distributed and modular
everything and the Internet of Things so
one of the big challenges that I saw in
clean tech 1.0 is when you had to go
build these really big plants and you
know let's say a biofuels plant you put
a bunch of money a new company you do
the science you do the engineering it
looks like it works then you go build a
pilot then you go build a demo then you
build a first commercial and none of
those are profitable
that is a lot of risk to take on and so
one thing that we're particularly
interested in is investing in
distributed modular technologies where
you can get in the market with and
actually be profitable and get into kind
of niche first markets with modular
smaller technologies as opposed to
having to bite off that multi hundred
million dollar bet before you have any
proof or any or any sort of de-risking
and then in terms of with advanced you
know information communication
technologies now we can control a lot of
these more smaller modular things in a
much more efficient way
generally speaking exponential
technologies obviously CMU is a big part
of this revolution but you know there
are a number of areas where you'd say
five years ago or today we're just not
there you know you know we'd love to be
able to to ferment you know wood into
this this fuel or high value molecule
but you know the technology is 10x away
but now that you've got synthetic
biology and and the exponential curves
of DNA synthesis and sequencing for
example those are in your sights if you
know where those technologies are going
right so we're paying a lot of attention
to exponential technologies very
importantly and this relates a lot to
our our investors is is the end the
nature of the problem this is a global
challenge right a lot of most of the
growth is going to be in China India
Africa Indonesia and so we're very much
setting ourselves up to be aware of and
investing around where the growth is
both investing in companies in North
America and Europe that will deploy in
emerging economies and going and finding
boots on the ground companies in those
geographies
and backing them and then finally
urbanization and so what we're seeing is
with the rapid move towards urbanization
we're much more interested in solutions
that are going to solve urban problems
than problems that are more of a rural
nature and so you can check out our
website there's an eye chart but we
started out when we launched with this
landscape of innovation it's got 55
technical quests or Grand Challenges but
since this was released you know
basically when we were launched we've
done a lot of work applying these
megatrends
looking at the half Gigaton
opportunities to identify a few thesis
investment areas that we're really
interested in and I'm going to talk to
you about
those they're by no means comprehensive
you may have ideas in other areas if you
got a half a Gigaton entitlement you got
a real business we want to talk and so
we're really we have sub teams you have
teams around these five sectors each of
which have very significant emissions
electricity power transportation
agriculture manufacturing and buildings
and I'm going to talk about examples of
things that were very interested in each
of those areas except for buildings and
but we are still very interested in
buildings just a matter of just the time
I have today so in electricity as I said
before we're really one of the big mega
trends that we are we are investing
around that we believe in we've analyzed
is this ultra low-cost renewable
electricity again we're seeing two three
cents per kilowatt hour wind and solar
PBA's we are being told that people
expect to see some of the first 1 cent
per kilowatt hour PBA's and wind in
north america coming up soon and you
know we it's slowing but we see this
continuing to move so what are the
opportunities and challenges that you
get when you can when you are in a world
awash in 1 2 3 cent per kilowatt hour
but intermittent or a low capacity
factor wind and solar and so one of the
areas that we're really interested in is
in ultra long duration grid storage so
this is as you're getting higher and
higher penetrations of wind and solar
you know what are the challenges you get
is that these are bidding into the
market when they're available right and
so essentially they bid in at zero
because they have no marginal cost no
fuel costs and so as you bid in more and
more you where you're you know if you're
a solar plant and you're bidding in the
middle of the day the more and more
solar there is the lower the price is
getting there's a bit of a falling knife
problem I think that when you get to
higher and higher penetrations of wind
and solar the price that you're gonna
get paid is getting lower and lower
lower and you're kind of chasing that
cost curve and so you need other
technologies in our view like grid
storage to help ameliorate the the
issues that you face around getting
really high penetrations of wind and
solar that you're going to need to
dramatically decarbonize the grid and so
lithium ion is going coming down so fast
we've done a lot of analysis Jays done a
lot of analysis in this area but you
know when we talked to experts they say
10 years from now they wouldn't be
shocked if a fully installed grid
storage plant with lithium ion is $150
per kilowatt hour and they definitely
wouldn't completely bet against it being
at $100 per kilowatt hour and we're more
like at about $500 per kilowatt hour
today and so you know that is low enough
to cover multiple hours right so let's
say five six seven eight hours that you
might need to provide some buffering of
renewable power provide some firming and
so I'd say on one hand were very
interested in any technology solution
that can get below that about $100 per
kilowatt hour any solutions that come to
us that are higher than that we think
it's probably a big gamble in terms of
where we see with the amaya I'm going so
that's kind of a floor so it we're
interested in things that are below $100
for kilowatt hour that have that
entitlement five to ten years from now
but I'd say something that we aren't
seeing a lot of people think about that
we're thinking about and this is a bit
of a noisy chart but you know you can
see lithium ion and the blue there where
we think this is a the duration of
storage versus the installed cost of
capital cost upfront $1.00 per kilowatt
hour and when you get to higher and
higher penetrations a big opportunity we
see are kind of two use cases that would
be in the like hundreds to thousands of
hours not just you know five to ten
hours but what that means is that these
are these applications you know are
needed let's say for let's say if you
had a base load wind plant right a wind
plant they could have this one cent per
kilowatt hour but be selling it at
prices that it could get in terms like a
base load asset but in order to do that
you need something that's on the order
of $20 per kilowatt hour and then when
you get to really high penetrations of
renewables in certain geographies 7080
plus which we see going down a future
and where RPS is are headed in some US
states and and and place like Germany
are moving in that direction that you
actually have this seasonal imbalance
right like the the amount of Sun that
you get on an average day in Germany and
higher
attitudes for example is very different
in the winter than it is in the summer
so you need to find ways to buffer
energy over over months you know over a
thousand hours and so the when you're
looking at the kind of base load
renewables case you need about something
like 20 cycles a year not a daily cycle
but something like 20 deep cycles a year
and you need to get down to about like I
said $20 per kilowatt or if you want to
do that seasonal you need to get into
the realm of like $1 per kilowatt hour
and so when we've been out talking to
the community this is a use case that a
lot of people hadn't thought of and
basically what it means is there are an
extremely limited set of materials that
are cheap enough to even go $20 per hour
or $1.00 per kilowatt hour and so you
end up having to try to figure out
here's the innovators challenge how do I
take sulfur how do I take super low cost
metals how do I take water how do I take
air how do I use these kind of very low
cost materials and make a storage system
that can be at that kind of cost and
what's also interesting is it really
relieves a lot of the constraints the
typical you know energy storage in this
case looking at like a battery or a flow
battery looking technology has you can
go way low or power and you only need to
do much limited numbers of cycles of one
cycle a year 20 cycles year as opposed
to 300 cycles a year which is what you
would need with a daily kind of
application so this is a problem we're
very interested in we're interested
engaging with innovators who have big
big ideas at that $20 per kilowatt hour
or even that dollar per kilowatt hour
cost point at the same time you know we
don't believe that storage is the
panacea right so you're gonna need in
addition to a lot of renewables that
wind and good amounts of very low cost
storage you're gonna need other
dispatchable scalable zero greenhouse
gas electricity sources so we're looking
at nuclear we're looking at CCS but in
terms of the megatrends I talked to you
about one area that I am particularly
interested in we're particularly
internal and so you know geothermal has
been really niche right it's like a
couple gigawatts it's you know 1% or
less of North American electricity and
if you look at most projections almost
all projections it's there for the next
3040 years out to 2050 but when you look
at when you look at the shale boom
there were projections at do-e of where
natural gas production would go and when
shale came in it diverged exponentially
and so we think there's a really
interesting intersectional opportunity
between the introduction the use of you
know for the first time no one's ever
done a horizontal well in the history of
geothermal to introduce horizontal
drilling and multi zonal fracturing
technology stimulation technology from
the oil and gas industry that's moving
on an exponential curve into the
geothermal space and we're working with
some innovators in this area we actually
think this there's a real shot that this
could be a game-changer that rides that
shale gas shale technology learning
curve in terms of transportation big you
know actually interesting is about 15
percent of global greenhouse gas
emissions which is kind of low as a
sector but that's gonna go up like crazy
as the rest of the world adopts
automotive automobiles everyone starts
buying cars all around the world and so
we've done a lot of analysis here as I
mentioned we're quite bullish in our
kind of internal analysis on the rate of
deployment of electrified vehicles and
so we tend to agree more with these
these kind of higher projections here
that at about 2030 gets you to about 20
million new evie sales light duty
vehicle sales per year and so what we
started thinking about is well you know
let's not think too near-term you know
there are definitely challenges for this
industry in the near term there are a
lot of companies getting after those but
in terms of you know what are the things
that could slow this down right in five
years 10 years 15 years what are the
things that when you do your analysis
and you think forward could turn this
exponential into a into and do an
up-and-down or a long flat flat part and
so we've been looking at both the
downstream so you know what kind of
charging infrastructure what kind of
charging rates are people going to need
to get like to get all those different
segments of people be willing to adopt
v's what kind of what kind of what kind
of a range are you gonna need you know
increasing the range increasing the
charging rate but then the other thing
we look at is upstream and so when an
industry is moving this fast it can
often be limited by the availability of
the fundamental materials
go into the thing and so we've
identified both cobalt and lithium as
two essential elements that that could
end up being a bottleneck for the growth
of this industry and so to look at just
one of those lights which I say is the
more severe is cobalt if you look at a
projection where you're at about 20
million EVs per year in that 2030 time
frame it's pretty shocking what happens
in terms of cobalt demand it goes from
this kind of $100 per kiloton level
that's been reasonably flat for a number
of years and to up to 400 or more
kilotons per year of demand and so any
of you that are familiar with with kind
of mineral or mining ore or metals kind
of industries a 4x over 10 years or so
is huge you know it's it's really hard
to deal with and particularly
interesting as we've dug in is almost
all of the supply up to that up to now
up to about the 100 kilotons has been as
a byproduct of other mining so you got
big copper mines you got big nickel
mines and they just kind of Slough this
stuff off and sell it as a co-product
but as the demand for cobalt grows like
crazy in the demand for copper and
nickel does not go nearly as fast it's
no longer enough just to get the the Co
production of the cobalt from those so
for the first time in history over the
next number of years we're gonna have to
go invent the technologies and go out
and have businesses go find cobalt
driven resources and find ways to
cost-effectively extract them so this is
an area that we're looking at and are
very interested in but as bullish as we
are in electrification when you look at
things like air transportation or
international and coastal shipping which
are each well over half a Giga ton of
emissions today electrification is not
happening for these you know even when
you're very bullish about electric
aviation short-haul it work when you're
bullish about you know a long-haul
trucking electrification in which we
think is is kind of a you know it's a
it's a middle-of-the-road kind of
proposition these are not going to be
electrified so what are we going to do
to get after these applications these
emissions and that is where we see the
need for cost-effective
low greenhouse gas emissions liquid
fuels and the two areas the way that
we're thinking about this is that if you
really want these to be carved
neutral greenhouse gas neutral you've
got to take co2 out of the air and put
it back in it's a cycle right and so the
two ways that we see that you can do
that is biofuels so we're taking a very
serious look basically there was a lot
of carnage as we all know in the in the
recent kind of biofuels wave for second
generation biofuels like cellulose and
biofuels a lot of progress but they
didn't quite get that and so we're
taking a fresh look at that and seeing
are there ways that we can put together
the puzzle pieces of the really amazing
technology that was developed in various
parts of the supply chain and put those
together in creative ways and also
perhaps leverage the latest
breakthroughs in synthetic biology to
deliver a biofuel company that can
actually deliver at cost that scale and
you know we've also been looking
seriously at co2 other co2 to fuels
technologies and so we're very
interested in carbon capture and
conversion to fuels and in the long run
if you want that to be carbon neutral
you have to be looking at air capture
and so we're looking quite seriously at
air capture as an important long term
part of the equation in terms of liquid
fuels as well one thing that is it has
been really fun for me is I'd say
probably most of us in the room are
would consider ourselves more energy
nerds than AG nerds I would guess right
you know it's an energy conference but
when I went from Department of Energy to
breakthrough energy from an energy
mission to a greenhouse gas focused
mission the one big new area that that I
was introduced to is really the food and
AG area which is a quarter of global
emissions and the three game-changers
that we really are focused on and that
are the big contributors to emissions in
this space are the provision of animal
protein which and these are these are
these don't add up they overlap a little
bit just to for the the math folks out
there is that animal protein is a seven
Giga ton per year they matter it's huge
and I'll tell you a little bit more
about that but two thirds of that comes
from just the existence of cows so cows
are a huge part of the problem here that
we're looking at food waste it's a huge
challenge that was shocked to learn is
basically the size the food waste
Shen's are the equivalent or they exceed
the emissions of the country of China
this is a huge problem and then nitrogen
fixation this is basically fertilizer
right you know fertilizer for for
agriculture both in terms of the energy
and emissions it takes to make ammonia
which is about 1% of global ghd's and
then the other part is when you don't
use the the ammonia very efficiently
that turns into n2 or nitrogen oxide
which is a really potent greenhouse gas
as well which is you know those are
about 50/50 in terms of impact of that
sector so we're very interested in
looking at you know this is an
exponential technology domain on the
nitrogen fixation side focusing maybe
more on the on the field we see a lot of
opportunities and a lot of great ideas
in the area of applying kind of
synthetic biology and microbiome to
nitrogen fixation you know there are a
very limited set of plants that could
actually fix their own nitrogen but
people haven't been able to port those
traits over to major crops like corn or
others and so we're excited about
looking at a number of companies that
are trying to tackle this issue of of
either dramatically improving the
utilization efficiency of fertilizer or
even a big vision of completely
eliminating the need for fertilizer by
pulling nitrogen straight out of the air
in terms of food waste I'll admit this
is a tough space this is a very
disaggregated space so it goes all the
way from losing crops in the field you
know where people have creative ideas
around around imperfect produce you know
like markets for carrots with two legs
all the way down to you know good
cooling solutions and transport
solutions or or inhibitors for ripening
or rotting all the way down to
innovations that would involve which the
worst place to waste food is when it's
right on your plate because you've
already invested so much in getting it
there and so ideas around like
innovative delivery models or other
models are all being considered there
but I'd say we're a little bit early and
our thinking there would be really open
to your creative and big ideas I'd say
the biggest opportunity we're pursuing
right now is in this low GH g protein
area and so two-thirds of this is the
cow about half
that cow emission comes from the whole
supply chain of just keeping that cow
alive and growing and the other half is
from an enteric fermentation so this is
the burping of methane and so we're
looking seriously at innovative ideas
for addressing you know the the methane
emissions are there microbiome
approaches that instead of emitting
methane would allow a methane conversion
in the gut
that's an interesting area to look at
the other is just to completely
eliminate the cow the other half of the
emissions and so we're looking seriously
at opportunities to provide at scale
you know palatable you know solutions
for food that would have much lower
greenhouse gas so there are ideas around
using plant-based materials and then
adding in small amounts of of kind of
specialty materials like heme like
impossible foods you may know about it
as a has a burger that is plant-based
but it actually tastes like a real
burger because it introduces these heme
or blood like additives at very small
percentages and then you've got
companies out there who are actually
taking mammalian cells and culturing
them in the lab and have a vision of
actually making you your whole steak
without the cow turns my stomach a
little bit right now but I think it's
very interesting it could have a huge
impact and then you know I think those
are some of the areas that we think are
a really big opportunity but another
thing that was really new to me coming
to this is that you know when you look
at all the emissions from the cow half
is from beef you know which half is
ground beef and the rest is kind of
different forms of beef the other half
is dairy and so if we can find really
innovative ways to create dairy either
like use fermentation or other
approaches to take plant-based molecules
and makes things that are the functional
equivalent of milk or if we can develop
other kind of milk substitutes that are
really preferable or palatable to people
that would have a huge impact on the
space as well so I think hopefully a
number of problems that that are kind of
new to you but these are areas that we'd
love to engage with innovators on
and then the final sector I wanted to
talk about is the what I think is the
hardest sector and this is
the industry sector this is making stuff
at scale and and so I consider that you
know there aren't a lot of really great
scalable ideas out there for these
sectors and this represents a third of
global emissions and I think there's I
think there's relatively less attention
paid by entrepreneurs and innovators in
this sector then there needs to be it we
really love to engage with people in
this area and the three big problems
that I'd say we it would our most
interested in is steel production which
is between two and three Giga tons
emissions cement production - and
ammonia production which is a key part
of the fertilizer emissions in the case
of steel you know it's really coming
from the coal that's being used to turn
iron iron ore or an oxide into iron and
so we think they're exciting
opportunities you know some of the best
ideas out there or potentially using
finding ways to make really cheap
hydrogen with no greenhouse gas
emissions and then using that to convert
the the iron ore instead of cold so and
so no emissions I'll talk about another
another angle in just a second and
cement is a really tough one and I say
like steel we're not seeing a lot of
really big ideas coming out of top
innovators in these areas a few but here
the real challenge is the Portland
cement you know like order of ten
percent of what goes into concrete is
incredibly emission intensive and
basically you take calcium carbonate
like chalk and you have to heat it up to
make calcium oxide and that not only
requires energy heat which about half
the emissions but you're also in that
chemical conversion making a lot of co2
and so you know innovative ways to
reduce the amount of Portland cement
that's needed completely new approaches
to cement alternatives to cement wood
based construction and other kinds of
things are all things that we're very
interested in and then in ammonia we see
some you know I think almost all the
emissions for ammonia are from making
hydrogen from natural gas so again I
think a game-changer there would be if
we could find ways to make hydrogen we
think you know if it's $1 to $2 per
kilogram you change the world and so
these are all areas we're very
interested in
the last thing I wanted to talk about is
something that actually Jay and I are
working together on and that I'm hopeful
breakthrough will we'll be partnering
with with Carnegie Mellon on to figure
out whether there might be a big
opportunity here and so generally
speaking I'd say you know the hardest
sector industry to decarbonize bridging
it to a sector that many are very
optimistic will be decarbonized more
rapidly and more efficiently and in a
more ready way the power sector so how
do we bridge electricity to the industry
sector so electrifying industrial
production and more specifically how do
we take advantage that's kind of a new
idea we'd love to
I'd love to engage with top innovators
out there on and Jay and I would love to
do that with you is how do we take this
1 to 2 cent per kilowatt hour
intermittent renewable electricity low
capacity affect electricity that we were
seeing come on in a larger larger scale
and more and more places and how do we
bridge that to make zero greenhouse gas
emissions stuff how do we bridge that to
make steel hydrogen ammonia if we could
do that in a cost-effective manner and
that power is really cheap which makes
it really possible especially using the
the most promising platform I see is at
electrochemistry things like an
electrolyzer electrolysis unit the big
technology challenge an opportunity here
is that that people haven't really
thought about using renewable
intermittent low capacity factor energy
to directly power industrial processes
and so the big difference here is you'd
have a factory you'd have a plant that
would only be able to operate 40% of the
time 50% of the time 25% of the time and
so you have to think in a completely new
way about dramatically reducing the
capital cost of these systems because
you're only using them part of the time
you're getting super cheap energy but
you're only getting a part of the time
so you've got to build it you got to
envision a new kind of factory that is
completely different that is
dramatically lower capital cost and so
this is something that that Jay and I
are gonna be looking at together so with
that I want to thank you for your time I
hope you got to know a little bit about
us I hope that some of these problems or
problems that you're interested in
tackling with us
bottom line I want to put out there is
is that we are we are here to support
your big ideas and it's really about
those big half Giga ton ideas and so
we've got a lot of work to do but we've
got a good amount of capital we've got
some great investors and we think
there's a tremendous opportunity to
build some of the biggest and most
successful companies in the world that
will go help us tackle this 70 Giga ton
gap thank you so much
[Applause]
we have time for a couple questions okay
very good thank you
fantastic thanks again for coming and
we've got a number of questions from the
audience so I'm just going to sort of
sit here and recite some of them mm-hmm
first what actually is another think big
point that some folks have raised as a
potential for geoengineering instead of
reducing carbon emissions I mean which
is obviously the right fight to fight
other folks are considering injecting
certain like sulfur species or other
things in the high atmosphere to reduce
the impact of the Sun and to reduce
global warming in a different way are
you guys considering that sort of thing
at all are you more focused on
mitigating the problem through carbon
reduction yeah you know we haven't
explicitly put it off the table but I'd
say for now we are very very focused on
greenhouse gas emissions and mitigation
and so there definitely a few folks out
there including high net worth folks who
are backing some teams that are looking
at some of these geoengineering things
but say for now we're completely focused
on reducing emissions and not focusing
on geoengineering great
what about what's your view on fusion
you know like I said I think that zero
zero greenhouse gas emissions
dispatchable generation which in a world
of high renewables penetration you're
going to need you're going to need very
low-cost technologies that are
dispatchable or firm and so you know we
believe that it is absolutely critical
for us to develop some number of
solutions that are going to scale you
know to at least kind of ten ten percent
or you know 15 percent of capacity that
can support those high of renewable
penetrations and so I'd say nuclear
fusion nuclear fission carbon capture
geothermal are all on the table but I'd
say there aren't a lot of no-brainer you
know obvious wins in that area so I
think we gonna have to look at a lot of
a lot of different things one thing
that's interesting though is that one
thing we been realizing is if you do
believe in a high or at least in
geographies that would have high
renewable intermittent renewable
penetration like wind and solar it's no
longer enough to just think of like an
LCOE
a base load plant LCOE for these kind of
dispatchable things because they're
gonna go up and down they're gonna be
operating at lower capacity factor and
so I think we're beginning to work on
some more appropriate metrics that we
should be having these kind of plants
target and so like the one thing I would
say is it like you know LCOE base load
that's not the right metric for these
dispatchable sources that we should be
targeting so someone else asked you know
this is actually a hybrid of a couple
different questions that I'm going to
put together you have to think big right
and and there is so much like many of
these solutions bridge outside the realm
of one country even right if you really
want to have it's a global impact it's a
global solution that suggests maybe also
there need to be some global or at least
nationally cogent policy drivers to
create incentive or to create space for
this are you guys looking at ways to do
that as well you can't maybe there's a
you know not just a technical solution
that's purely economically beneficial it
may need a nudge one way or another are
you is be evey because it's so different
than its mission gonna position itself
like that as well yeah so break their
energy ventures is is just one activity
I'd say that that these you know 21
high-net-worth you know influential
visionaries are backing and so but I'd
say a breakthrough we are very focused
on building great companies and so like
we're you know everything we do is
around building those great companies
that may involve some some thoughtful
engagement around with policy makers
around those companies but in terms of a
broader you know policy policy analysis
and potential advocacy you know I'd say
one thing we have is a sister
organization that the breakthrough
Energy Coalition which was the thing
that was announced at the cop21 meeting
from which breakthrough energy ventures
came is is now getting very active in
terms of bringing together major
companies high net worth influential
individuals and innovators entrepreneurs
to engage around the right kind of
analysis you know independent
independent analysis and engagement some
thoughtful advocacy around around what
kind of policies would allow innovation
to
prosper and get into the market and then
a number of our our backers are Twitter
with their own with their own money
backing all kinds of different policy
policy efforts around the world
great it's what I expected um because
you're still plugged in though there's
there is some inside baseball which
could be helpful I think really
important so let's talk some numbers
some a couple other questions they're
asking things like how large actually is
this fun is it gonna continue to grow
are you gonna do typical rounds like
Roma number one there were two funding
or is there evergreen fund
how many ventures per year you expect it
to go with that kind of thing it's a
great question so it's a little more
than a billion dollars in this fund
itself it's a it's a 20 year fund but
you know by no means does that mean that
we're gonna be likely making our you
know like first investments out of this
fund in year eighteen right so you know
it's over the next few years anywhere
we're looking to really deploy that
capital into great businesses you know
for first investments and then we've got
that that patients on the back end to
keep with the companies as they're
moving forward if you know if building a
great company is gonna take fifteen
years we can do that right if it's gonna
take 18 years we can do that but we're
looking to deploy that capital earlier
in the cycle and right now you know this
is the fund and this is the fun we're
focused on but one thing that I'm
thinking that occurred to me I remember
early on when I was talking to a mentor
of mine and I was saying well what was
different about this fun and was
exciting one of the things I said is and
we've got a billion dollars that's big
and he reminded me in the in the area of
Energy and Climate a billion dollars is
not that big and so I think one thing
that we're very aware of is this hast if
this is going to make a difference this
is the beginning of something this isn't
the end of something yeah I just just
got done teaching my class and we
reminded them that bp's revenue last
year was like a hundred and eighty five
billion dollars so just one year of one
company
one last follow-on on this - is there a
sense that you're gonna be putting cash
and reserve for each of your ventures
for follow-on investing or are you
looking at seeding and hoping other
people will pick up more slack down
there we're definitely gonna be
reserving capital for companies and any
will do in a different way given that
we're looking to support these companies
for a long haul and these are often
capital intensive businesses I also say
excuse me
relative to the more traditional fund I
think we're gonna be much more you even
more interested in syndicates and
collaboration and co-investment because
these problems are hard and they require
you know a reasonable amount of capital
and we want to make sure that and so
we're you know there are some had
investors who are kind of trying to
crowd out others I think we're gonna be
quite the opposite we're looking to pull
in other investors around that the
investments that we're doing time for
maybe one or two more questions someone
asks I didn't see much discussion around
building or building efficiency we all
know that efficiency improvements can
have a huge impact if you guys have is
that part of your thesis or are you more
focused on because individual companies
may be more focused on power sources and
uses is that a reasoning that you're not
focusing on your talk yeah you know
buildings is big so it's something we
care a lot about and I you know you can
only talk about so many things in one
talk so I have a slide on buildings but
it didn't present it today I'd say one
of the areas were most interested in
buildings is in zero greenhouse gas
associated heating and cooling that's a
huge portion of all of the energy we use
in buildings my personal opinion is that
lighting with the advent of LEDs and the
rapid penetration is maybe less of an
important area for us to focus but I
don't think we have a similar innovation
on a similar cost curve in HVAC space
we've also been looking at you know kind
of creative things around the the
embedded footprint of buildings that
looks back at materials and so one of my
colleagues is looking very seriously at
how do you expand the envelope of wood
based construction where you know you're
actually you get a two-bagger where
you're you're you're displacing steel
and concrete and you're also
sequestering carbon there through
biomass and so I'd say that there are a
number of areas that were very
interested in buildings but I think
buildings are tough and I ran the
buildings program at DOA it's a tough
space and so you know we're definitely
going to be in there but I think we're
gonna have to do some creative things to
make a real difference there all right
so last question this is a riff on one
that that someone submitted that I'll
add a bit to having fought the fight
personally or not personally but the
company that I founded along with a
bunch of other people
aqueon we went up against multinationals
in the battery storage space and
eventually had a difficult ending
quieted a great loss bad the company
continues but none of the initial
investors are in the game and one of the
things that we thought of or you know
towards the end was wow we really should
have aligned ourselves with a
multinational early on to co-develop and
make sure that our particular
manufacturing and our approach was
amenable to what was happening globally
with these huge companies that have were
bankable and had a lot more cash are you
guys looking to encourage this kind of
collaboration early on with these new
companies yeah a double meaning of that
I mean this is a situation because at
some point if it's a real thing in this
competition it's difficult to keep your
current flow no I'm I agree with you
wholeheartedly the you know
interestingly so we chose not to have
companies as limited partners and our
fund and I think because we appreciate
that we do need to work with a large
number of these companies to partner you
know I think that might have been a
cleantech one auto weakness in strategy
was is like we're gonna go head-to-head
with these companies as opposed to
finding win-win ways to collaborate and
you know I teach a energy ventures class
at Stanford where we try to teach the
next generation of entrepreneurs the
lessons you know of 1.0 and and what are
what is a playbook a new playbook that
we should be thinking of as company
builders and entrepreneurs in this space
to have better outcomes and you know I
kind of feel like as I look at that
playbook you know let's say they're you
know 10 chapters it kind of like we have
five of them the five or six of them
that are reasonably well worked out
but I would say that the chapter on on
like how do you do
these win-win strategic partnerships
with the big corporates in a way that
that can preserve and make sure you can
still make money and build great
businesses but leverage the the
capabilities of those big companies is
still being written
so we're gonna be engaging in a big way
but I think that there's still a lot of
back-and-forth that needs to happen to
make sure that the the right kinds of
deals the right kind of partnerships get
struck perfect well thank you so much
for coming and spending time with us I
think everyone here I learned a lot I
surely did and come back again
frequently thanks Susanna